[Music]
here's a quick look at the agenda we'll
do a bit of level setting around big
data challenging opportunities but then
very quickly we're going to move to the
second part of the session which we're
going to go through a hypothetical
retail scenario to do a lot of demos and
hands-on usage of the product and I'll
really show you in practice how they
work what they do
and then as mentioned Hayden will come
and talk about molecules experienced in
real life using those services to build
their application so speaking of the big
attack challenges to a large extent I
assume most of you knew no nodos
firsthand just having experienced them
I'm not going to know at least all of
them but among all of you know some of
the obvious one around the technical
difficulties of setting up and managing
and optimizing infrastructure ingesting
data and the one in that list which is
the the most near and dear to my heart
is really around five six seven it's
about you know not just kind of the
basics of of course you need data system
and capabilities but what we really need
to do is change the way people interact
and get value from data and move to a
much more interactive sorry
iterative and an explorative mode where
now things people have the freedom to
experiment you know it doesn't take a
long time to try something it doesn't
cost a lot of money to try something and
so it really changed the dynamic of how
people work with data and that's really
when you know when I see customers get
to that point that's when I know that
they're being successful on the platform
you know then getting to having X amount
of data on the platform that says
nothing then getting to the point where
they're really changing the way they get
inside that is the key moment and one
part of that is the collaboration also
seeing collaboration enabled by the
services that we describe within one
organization or even across organization
is also one of those aha moments where
you know we move from traditional Big
Data just easier to a different way to
value to get value from the data so
hopefully you'll see that in practice
in terms of you know what it's used for
it depends a lot in the various
industries obviously some aspects are
pretty common across industries you know
most companies have marketing a
marketing department know most companies
hopefully all of them have a financial
have financial data and actually make
money and I'm gonna keep track of it and
some of the use cases are much more
specific you know to inventory
management in retail or you know
maintenance in in manufacturing and
things like that so you know you know
better than me what your industry is
about but these are a typical example
that we see quite often in this session
when we say big data we really include
AI and ml in that context now here at
next there are many sessions around AI
so we're not gonna go into the details
of it but the way we think about it the
way we've built the platform is that AI
is really the prolongation of a data
platform it's not something that you
know you do instead of a data platform
you still have to have control of your
data use you have to bring the data and
understand your data but it really is an
extended set of capabilities that that
you know a part of the platform and
that's how we've built it and we'll
describe this integration as well as we
go through the session so very quick
level overview of the portfolio will
describe many of those services in in
practice through the demos but an easy
way to think about it is to break down
the life cycle of the data in four main
stages starting on the left side by
ingestion and and whether you're talking
real-time ingestion no and we'll talk
about pop soda as an even broker that's
often used for that or batch mode
ingestion and we'll talk about transfer
service or know many other ways to
integrate data and bring it to the
platform after that phase of ingestion
typically data needs to be prepared now
sometimes that eye comes in almost ready
and so you really just have to move it
to the right place but you know by and
large most of the time it needs some
level of preparation some level of
cleaning and
Richmond and so we'll talk about
services like data flow and data Prague
that support that and actually do the
work as well as tools like data prep
which is a very easy to use GUI driven
tool that allows non-technical
specialists to do their own data
preparation and so that allows no data
preparation but then that stage of the
lifecycle also more and more is where
some of the analytics happen some of the
ethics happens in real time we'll show
that here in the case of off of the
retail example but of course data then
is stored and analyzed and we'll talk
about bigquery for analytics and and
that our housing and then downstream I
mentioned ml I know there are science
will show the visualization tools just
the places where the data is actually
used and consumed by user so very
high-level overview and the point here
is that this session we'll talk about
the four life cycle and GCP that a
platform is built to address the full
lifecycle so we'll talk about individual
services and their capabilities but in
the end maybe the most important thing
is actually not what each service does
it's what they have in common it's the
key principles that are at the
foundation of Google Cloud and that
drive do we know and that shines through
all of those services so one of them
being integrated we know the last thing
we want is data silos and a lot of
customers especially those who move from
on-premise system they're moving for a
very siloed view of the world we know
some data is in the dye warehouse some
data is in the Hadoop cluster some data
is somewhere else
and where the data is limits what you
can do with it and so this we we've know
a long time ago rejected internally and
when time came for us to BL goggle cloud
we've brought that philosophy of
separating processing from data and
having data in all storage system
accessible from all pricing system and
we'll see that in practice and it has a
drastic effect you know it's simpler
it's more effective but going back to
the collaboration and exploration use
cases I described it really opens up the
door to a lot more
a much faster usage and collaboration
serverless is the other big one it's the
fact that moving to cloud doesn't not
just mean not dealing with hardware
anymore
that's a very basic version of cloud
moving to cloud really should mean not
having to worry about the how about the
infrastructure allowing you to focus on
bringing your business expertise your
understanding of the data describing
what you want to get done and that's it
and having the platform just make it
happen
and without you having to set up set up
machine or you know configure clusters
and and decide how many workers you need
things like that you know server less
takes that burden away from you and we
take care of it
and then finally openness everything we
do is either a cloud native service that
we built from the start as a
multi-tenant server layer system or a
service so we took the best of
open-source and brought it to Google in
the first case even though it's
something that all here at Google we
always open source the tool itself the
SDK the relevant pieces such that as you
use those cloud native services on
Google cloud what you're using is open
source tools standard interfaces search
that there's never any locking and there
is a rich community that builds on top
of those tools and we'll sell that in
practice when we talk about some of
those tools so let's now move to the
second part of the session and win is
going to set up the stage for you on the
the hypothetical example that we'll use
for that okay thank you very much
William so in my hometown of Sydney in
Australia I go to Bill's grocer or not
exactly Bill's grocer but a chain very
much similarly named so in this example
I've thought about what a scaled version
of Bill's grocer might look like if you
had multiple sales channels and
nationwide networks of physical stores
as well as a online presence where he
can sell groceries online so in this new
version of Bill's grocer where they're a
multinational chain potentially and with
multiple sales channels I thought about
the sort of data analytics that Bill's
grocer might want to perform
so the first might be to
the different types of bombing channel
interactions associated with the selling
channels for example on Bill's grocer's
website those grocer will want to
understand how are people actually
interacting with the website where they
actually leaving before they make a
purchase
how can bills groceries the actual
website experience on the physical sales
channel front if we look at
point-of-sale analytics there's a lot of
insight there Bill's gross that could
stand to advantage in themselves in
terms of how they optimize their
business for example if we're to go
beyond what are the typical sales
volumes and types of products that are
being bought more advanced analytics can
contain things like what are commonly
bought products that are bought with
other products in store and how can that
affect placement of individual products
in store now even though in this my
imaginary version of Bill's grocer is
now a very large chain because they want
to retain the small-town local grocer
feel Bill's grocer wants to still
continue to maintain that close customer
relationship and thereby understand
customer feedback through various
different means but also be able to
scale that as well
so in my imaginary scenario we're going
to incorporate some methods to
understand its customers sentiment and
feedback at scale as our batch
processing scenario so in terms of the
solution goals I think William alluded
to a lot of the things and
characteristics that you should try and
find within a data platform and we're
trying to encompass this within our
solution today so even though Bill's
grocer if from a small business through
some I large imaginary business whatever
the size Bill's grocer should not be
focused on infrastructure or the
machinery the mechanics required to run
data systems at scale rather like you
Jules grocer wants to focus on the
insights that can be derived from data
and that involves more than just being
able to process and store data at scale
but to be able to convert data into
insight quickly one of the ways that
we'll do this today is to incorporate
streaming analytics into our different
scenarios and show how you can convert
data into different insights that can
benefit the business as quickly as
possible doing lots of advanced queries
to generate insight is only one part of
the equation another part of the
equation is how people actually work
with insights and how to communicate
information at different stakeholders so
as part of our demonstration scenario we
shown different types of tools that are
targeted at different types of users
where there is technical users or
business stakeholders that it's actually
commensurate with the type of usage that
they will get from the system or the
type of insights they want to derive so
be showing different visualization tools
as well as collaboration tools that
integrate directly into the platform as
we scale analytics it's important that
we don't ignore data privacy concerns so
as a part of our scenario will be
showing different technologies that
allow you to factor in private
information and avoid having that
exposed in our analytics pipeline so
we'll be showing some api's that will
accomplish that capability at scale and
then lastly with the combination of all
these different elements we'll hopefully
have a system ready for bills grocer
that will not just mean a happy set of
customers but ultimately those happy
customers leading to a happy business
for bill so with that I want to pass
back to William to elaborate sure thank
you can I take the books thank you so
when we talk about the tool set maybe
one way to set the stage to help
understand how we came to the stage
where we are right now is to think about
the history of that our pricing at
Google which as you can imagine started
long before Google had a cloud you know
what for the first part of its existence
Google was only building technology for
its own use you know starting research
and other services and so when you start
a company with the goal to index the
entire web obviously you have a scale
problem from day one but also solving
scale is actually not the hardest part
or harness part solving scale
efficiently doing it in a way that's
very cost efficient from a resource
perspective also from a human
productivity perspective and that's how
Google can offer services for free it's
really dealing with scale and
productivity and so there's a long list
of papers that were published you know
those are internal technology that are
now known to the world because Google
publish papers and at the time Google
just publish the papers and then moved
on you know to develop the next internal
system people outside Google reading
those papers and learning what how
Google was using that I wanted to have
access to them and at the time the only
way to have access was to re-implement
it and so systems like Hadoop and HBase
and others were created basically by
reimplemented o--'s papers that had been
published in a rural perspective that
that was fine that's why we published
the paper but we were not involved in in
those non-google use cases that change
with the advent of cloud in several ways
so what has not changed is we still
publish papers so recently
data flow and tensorflow and there are
more coming up that are in review stage
but now what we publish a paper we also
open source the code behind it and so
tensorflow is now open source Apache
beam which we'll talk about a bit more
later is the result of Google open
sourcing the dataflow SDK giving it to
the Apache foundation and so instead of
having to re-implement people can now
use that using the code that Google uses
internally and the services themselves
are made available on Google Cloud and
so we'll start with bigquery as a first
example and then we'll talk about some
others so don't be query kind of the
successor of the original Dremel engine
which of course has seen a lot of
improvements and and re-engineering over
the last ten years but is you know one
of the workhorses of data processing at
Google available as a cloud service so
let's talk a bit more about bigquery in
a way you know the the one-line
description is a cloud data warehouse
and that's just that's both good and bad
you know in a way it's true because
anything data warehouse can do bigquery
can do you know you use standard sequel
to interact with it you can use all your
favorite data visualization tools you
know it has ODBC JDBC drivers and API or
CLI a rich ecosystem of partner you know
it is a true first-class enterprise data
warehouse it's also more than that in
the way that it's a cloud native data
warehouse and
his demo will we'll call out some of the
aspect it's serverless
it's separate storage from from
processing and as we announced this
morning it also has a lot of much of new
capabilities that make it much more
versatile and so this morning we
announced bigquery ml to do machine
learning directly in the query using
sequel we also announced an upcoming
feature to have GIS queries so geo geo
queries based on you know location
information in your data that allows you
to query in a you know in a geo specific
way and so that's another example of the
versatility of bigquery that it is
pretty core to the system one aspect is
how do you get data into bigquery you
know because to be useful it has to have
data now that being said there's already
a lot of public data sets that are
available directly in bigquery and so
you can go and try and use it at large
scale without bringing your own data but
most customers obviously want to bring
their own data many ways to do that a
lot of marketing data can be brought
automatically especially if it's already
at Google you know if it's adds data our
analytics data or if it's you know if
you're a YouTube publisher all of that
data you can just say I want that there
are brought into bigquery you have
nothing to do there other than just
saying I want it we have a rich
ecosystem of partners in the ETL data
integration space to bring data from
enterprise software unprimed from you
know other clouds and and SAS vendors
and then on the right side if you want
to you know if you build system that
right to be query B query is very well
equipped to do streaming ingestion and
so events you know flying through
pub/sub or other streaming system you
can have them flow into bigquery and be
immediately available in your queries
you know you just pump events and and
query on them so very easy very
optimized for streaming ingestion as
well of course as supporting batch
ingestion through GCS Google Cloud
Storage including taking advantage of
the many ways you can bring data to GCS
including cloud storage transfer service
to you know bring that are online
off-line you know you can bring
petabytes using physical devices and
many ways to bring that out to GCSE that
can flow then into bigquery and so let's
see that in practice and Reza will show
us thank you great okay so what we're
gonna do is run some queries against a
couple of data sets
now Wynn mentioned clickstream data so
this is the data coming from the
websites so we're gonna run a query
against cool data that we've obtained by
Google and x360 premium that has been
loaded into bigquery we're also going to
run some queries against a transactional
point of sale data set now this is
actually a petabyte of data that we're
gonna run some queries against just to
show the ability of bigquery to run
queries against very large data sets now
before we start I'd like to point out
one of the pieces that William brought
up around big queries architecture so
bigquery separates processing from
storage which is part of the reason it
is able to do what it can do but what
does that mean to you so the first thing
it provides is that if you're not
running any queries on bigquery you
don't need to pay for any servers that
are sitting around waiting for work so
that's one aspect the other aspect is
around the sharing of data both within
the eggs within the organization and
from external sources with to the
organization so how does that work if we
think about a traditional database you
have your software that you install into
some machines then you attach Sandoz
disk etc this thing becomes a unit you
then push information into it and now to
get access to that information you
either need to give access directly to
the database I used to be a DBA this is
not something I would let people do very
easily or you have an application layer
that you need to build on top then deal
with things like multi-tenancy etc or
you do the ftp dance and nobody likes to
do the ftp dance it's tedious and boring
and leads to lots of problems so what
we're going to do is actually show this
separation of processing of storage what
it means here we have a new bigquery
user interface it was recently pushed
out with this new version for those of
you who've used bigquery before on the
top here we can see that I am in the da
101 project
the project I am going to be running my
queries from on the left-hand side as
well as the da 101 project we can
actually see other projects that I have
been granted access to so through the
proper security and authorization they
see all mechanisms I've been given
access to these datasets now this
particular dataset the retail petabyte
dataset which I'm going to highlight
here has some tables in it and again
this is a table that exists in a
different project I've just been given
access to it so I'll run my query from
here against that this sales partition
table just to look at the the structure
it's got a sales order key this is that
point-of-sale sales information and if
we look at the types of data that we're
allowed to store as well as the standard
one you have here we have a record type
so this record there's a single sales
order key and there are many lines of
information because bigquery supports
repeated fields within a column so let's
go and actually look at some more
details around this table so here we're
going to start discovering that despite
the name bills grossers is actually
hugely successful because they have over
1 petabytes of data in their sales
information which we can highlight here
and over 1 trillion
rows of information so that's a lot of
sales that these guys have been making
I'm assuming it's a very big Bill's
grocer now what we're going to do is
going to run a deliberately inefficient
query so this particular query that I'm
going to run I'm going to try and find
the sales information per day for a
particular customer denoted by this
customer key I'm going to kick that off
now that's going to take a little while
to complete just to note
actually that was cheating let me turn
off caching so bigquery will cache
results of a query that's been recently
run for up to 24 hours let me run that
again so that's now going to take a
little while to complete what I'd like
to point out on the right-hand side is
even though there's a petabyte of
information in that table we're only
going to process 31 terabytes
still a pretty big number and we're
still going to process all of the rows
the reason for that is bigquery has a
column Rio storage structure so what
that means is if you're going to only
access a few of the columns from the
table within your select statement it
only needs to process those columns and
it ignores the rest of the data so here
it doesn't need to access any other
columns other than the three we have in
this query now because that's going to
take a little while to run I'm going to
quickly move over to another tab and
show some of the other features of
bigquery so first of all well like to
point out is this is the area that we
can actually start building our queries
against so we can start typing in and we
can do all to complete the however when
we're doing ad-hoc queries etc it's
obviously nice to have a scratch pad
area so somewhere where you save your
queries for use by yourself later on so
for that if we look at saved queries we
have two environments we have the
personal queries which is my personal
area where I can leave queries that I
want to come back to or if you want to
share your query so you've built that
beautiful query 30 lines long and you
want to share it with your colleagues
and show off we can actually do that
through project queries so here we can
save our queries and then share it with
my colleagues like William and Wynne who
can then go and access this query work
on it or run it and we're going to
choose a particular query which is this
Google Analytics 360 data this
particular query is going to look at the
clickstream data that's been imported
from Google knowledge 360 and it's going
to tell me where which sources have
generated the most bounce rates from our
data set now why bounce rate we mean a
user has just come and not viewed any
more pages on the first page they came
to so if I first of all I'm going to
load this query in you see it's been
loaded into the top here I'm gonna run
this query now and that will take about
five six seconds to complete it's
finished and we can see here that it's
gone through the Google Analytics 360
data and provided insights to us about
the sources of the that have been sent
I've been sending clicks to us and the
number of visits the number of times
that we've only landed on a single page
just to show some of the other features
of bigquery so on this side I'm going to
create a dataset which is the container
that we can load
into here we have the data set ID but on
data locations we can choose several
regions United States European Union or
Tokyo so these are the regions that the
data will reside in when we create this
data set in terms of the other functions
here we have a default table expiration
so this is super useful when you're
actually building out some queries
sometimes you want to build some
temporary tables there's a couple of
reasons you want to do that for example
you're running a particularly large
query and you want to explore the data
set that's the result of that large
query so for that you'll just run the
large query create this table and you
want it you don't want to then have to
think about deleting it afterwards so by
setting creating a data set with this
exploration level we can say number of
days there let's say we create a data
set called temporary we can create these
temporary tables and know that after
about 5-6 days they're automatically
going to get cleaned up for us the other
reason you obviously need two temporary
tables is when you are building a
particularly large query and it's very
useful sometimes just take out that
inner part of that query while you
explore the outer outer parts I'm going
to now also I said that the query that
we were running against that very large
data set was inefficient just to show a
more efficient version of that query
using some features that recently
released round clusters and a slightly
older feature around partition tables so
if I go to save queries and look at our
project queries and customer cluster
optimized so I'm going to open this one
so this particular query is making use
of some dates to limit the the call and
it's using specific range of customer
keys if we look at this sales partition
clustered table it is of a similar size
to the table we saw before around a
petabyte however when I run this query
it's actually going to compete in talked
about again
I really need to turn this off
so this will complete about 10 to 20
seconds and if we look on the right-hand
side it's actually having to process a
lot less data and the reason for that is
it's actually using some smarts around
because the partition table is by date
it's very able to prune information it
doesn't need to access and it's
clustered by our customer key so that is
going to completely open in a few more
seconds there we go that was a result of
that one finishing 18 seconds and now
we're going to go back to the original
query and here we see that that larger
query process 31 terabytes went through
the trillion rows in two minutes and
just a few seconds on top of that now
what the last we want to show you here
is this table stock if I go to this
stock table and look at details we
expand this further up here and I'm not
able to use the scroll bar there we go
we notice that it's actually got a
streaming buffer of stats underneath one
of the things that we didn't mention is
that bigquery supports insert streaming
inserts directly into bigquery which
means we can continuously update tables
and when we make a query call it's using
the latest data
so here the point-of-sale system is
continually updating sales to bigquery
and when we run a query it's going to be
with the most up-to-date data now if we
can go back to the slides okay can have
the ticker so how do we get that
streaming so one of the ways is through
the API that bigquery directly exposes
and you can build applications that use
that API directly however most of the
customers I work with will actually use
other mechanisms to be able to do this
predominantly using things like pub/sub
and data flow so if we think about a
streaming pipeline when we've got
messages coming in and we need some way
of actually absorbing those messages and
Google cloud pub/sub is our global
publish and subscribe API it's able to
absorb messages onto a topic and it also
acts as a very good shock absorber so if
you imagine you have a very high spike
in requests that you weren't expecting
or you have some problems downstream
pub/sub will retain information for up
to seven days and i've seen it used very
effectively in that mode where
quite a few customers as so now that
we've got a way of actually absorbing
these messages we need a way of
transporting them from pub/sub over to
the bigquery table and for that we're
going to use data flow which allows you
to do batch and stream processing in a
distributed way being able to scale out
at very large scale if we think of the
end-to-end pipeline here we have the
point-of-sale system there is an
application that is writing the messages
into pub/sub as sales are happening data
flow is doing a very simple task here
which is to transport those messages
from pub/sub over to bigquery using that
streaming API which allows us to get
queries immediately up-to-date on what's
happening within the business so when I
first started doing this I've been at
Google or five years we tended to have
to write code to spin up any dataflow
pipeline and that was even for the
simple stuff here since then we've
actually got these fantastic templates
which allows you to go to a UI complete
the templates and it will automatically
transport the information from pub/sub
to bigquery spinning up data flow in the
background and to actually see that in
action win is going to show us a demo
thank very much Rosa okay so let's go
back to the cloud platform console and
there's a few things that we need to get
the first streaming pipeline that we
want to run working the first part is
pub/sub so let's go into the pubsub
configuration the first thing that we
need to do in pubsub is to create a pub
subtopic that we'll be using to read or
ingest messages from a streaming source
in this particular case we'll be using a
hypothetical point-of-sale system that
will be sending messages to the pub
subtopic let's go ahead and create the
topic to do that I click on the create
topic button I give it a unique ID like
paws data click create and there I have
my new topic it is now ready to accept
streaming messages the second part that
I need to perform is to provision the
data flow pipeline to do that I can use
one of the pre-prepared templates that
lets me create the
a flow pipeline take the messages from
the pub subtopic and then write them
into a bigquery table in order to do
that here is a existing template
configuration that I've already pre
typed out so that you don't have to
watch me continually make syntax errors
all these details are all you need to
have a simple pipeline that takes the
pub/sub messages right to a big free
table or without code I'm going to click
on run job here to provision the job and
the next screen that I'll be taken to
will show the pipeline being provisioned
as well as a way to visualize the actual
data flow graph itself now because it's
going to take a little bit of time as in
maybe 60 90 seconds something like that
to really get the pipeline up and
running I'm going to go into a
pre-prepared pipeline which already has
data streaming in turn to show you some
of the more important parts of the data
flow interface the first is obviously
the pipeline itself what you see here
with the different rectangles in
organized as I said of connected nodes
in a graph is actually the different
transformations and operations on the
data that the pipeline is performing in
order to read the messages do some
simple transformation and then write to
an output table so the pub/sub messages
transformation is represented by this
box which is for reading the pub/sub
messages on the right-hand side you see
some interest interesting information
about the actual step itself the step is
parallelized across different data flow
workers which means that because we're
running a distributed service that can
scale to really any sort of data scale
that you want to throw into the pipeline
you can see what the performance of the
pipeline is like in the context of the
number of different data elements I have
been added are added in history as well
as the size of all the elements that
been processed by that particular step
now if I actually don't click on any
step at all you see some overall
statistics about the pipeline so if you
look into order scaling we can see that
currently if there's one worker
operating all the different steps of the
pipeline itself there's not a lot of
data flowing inside the pipeline at the
moment so right now one worker is
sufficient as more data goes into the
pipeline the dataflow service as a
service offering will automatically
scale up a number of workers to meet the
volume and throughput that is needed by
your application so all that stuff is
without you needing to configure any
infrastructure or to configure any
concerns about scaling you can see
within the pipeline that there's other
information shown like the number of
elements processed within each step so
for example we have 24 elements a second
being written out to our target table
within bigquery so again it's low volume
but that shows you some more interesting
information about what your pipeline is
actually doing now that we've explained
the dataflow pipeline let's actually
look at the output of the streaming
dataflow pipeline itself in the context
of the bigquery tables being written to
so I'm gonna go into the bakery
interface again and again save me on
typing I'm going to bring up a save
query which I prepare pre-prepared ahead
of time and bring up this particular
query which I will run very shortly but
I've actually omitted a particular part
which is actually get some real-time
data on stage right now so I'd like to
actually bring up a razor into the
demonstration as well actually why don't
you stand here reso because I think it's
better if you operate from there I'm
going to need to do some inelegant out
tabbing here so I did say that this is a
point-of-sale demonstration so I did say
is hypothetical but we did go to the
effort of actually building a
hypothetical green screen point-of-sale
application which as you can see is very
very attractive and Reza's here is going
to help me purchase some products at one
of bills Gross's stores I'm an
Australian and I always get very
homesick whenever I travel so I want to
buy some goodies here to basically show
and through the long days of the travel
there we go alright one answer there and
these are delicious
and to their this one is actually my
favorite there we go all right okay so
you can definitely see that I'm a bit of
a chocolate fan are you gonna say you
know what I'm very jealous right now
I can't eat yet so maybe I'll eat after
this particular demo is done so what's
actually happened here is I've purchased
four products each time a product has
been purchased
there's a streaming pub/sub message
written to the pop sub topic which is
then with red using our data flow
pipeline processed and then written to
our output big free table all in
near-real-time
so we see here that the current invoice
number is this so let's go and check the
outputs of our table so actually I think
I need a copy this so that I don't get
it wrong and I'm going to crew the table
that should have received the output run
the query and with some luck
I should see the products that I've just
bought so there you go a streaming
pipeline taking data from a real-time
streaming source or without code back to
you William thank you I'm gonna switch
back to the demo to the slides so what
we saw here is that pipeline where you
can use data flow without having to
write any code sorry I'm clicking on the
wrong screen there we go without having
to write any code because the data flow
pipeline that was executing has been
pre-created no for a given task to bring
that up from pub/sub to bigquery now
data flow can do that but the luffler
can do a lot more than that it's really
a full fledge pricing system and so
let's talk more about the broader range
of capabilities of data flow and again
going back to this historical view where
there are flow comes from is really two
things flume Java is a system that we
developed at Google as a replacement for
MapReduce a more efficient easier way to
create and run large scale at apprising
pipelines in batch mode in parallel
another team created near will which is
a system for stream processing
because at that time there was a clear
move within Google to real-time that are
processing and mill-wheel met that need
in that I flow what we've done is we've
brought those two separate services
together and unify them in dataflow so
its unified from a programming
perspective we're the same pipeline can
run in batch or in stream mode it's also
unify for an execution environment where
one service you can submit the pipeline
and it runs both of them and so that's
really the genesis of dataflow having
done that and kind of delivering on that
openness philosophy that I described we
open source the dataflow SDK we give it
to the Apache foundation where it's now
called Apache beamer and beam the B of
beam is stands for batch and the EAM
stands for stream and so really that
what that name represents is a
unification of batch and stream in one
programming model and that's one thing
that's really really important to beam
is that because it maps to a real need
where more and more we see companies
move from a very bad centric view to a
more real-time view but that doesn't
happen overnight you know it's a
progressive process where you know some
of your sources some of your pipelines
move and when that happens you don't
want to have to re-implement your
business logic you just want to be able
to take your pipeline and say hey you
know that what used to be a file drop
every four hours is now a streaming
pipeline run the same business logic on
this data and don't make me rewrite it
and so beam does that very well also
works the other way around I have a
streaming pipeline but once a while
I want to reprocess historical
information no problem take the pipeline
run it in batch mode again historical
information and so that is something
that is that is a characteristics of
beam itself in Apache and the Apache
work is actually not tied to Google in
any way and so those beam pipelines that
you write can run anywhere you want they
can run on a spark cluster they can run
on other Apache processing system like
flink if you're familiar with flink
or just recently our friends are linked
in open source or sam's our runner
there is one for apex there are one for
gear pump and so there many different
systems well you can run those pipelines
Google Cloud dataflow is just another
one you know and so the pipelines are
portable if you run them on that a flow
what you get is the benefit of a server
less environment and so you don't have
to deploy a cluster and then run your
pipelines you just submit the pipeline
just tell Google run this for me in bash
moon or run this for me in stream mode
and Google automatically provisions the
right amount of workers continuously o2
scares them through the life of the
pipeline and executes the pipeline and
you don't have to worry about any
infrastructure you just have to write
your pipeline describe what you want to
get done and that's really the core of
dataflow from an operational perspective
one thing I would add is data flow is a
very generic very versatile data
processing mechanism for any kind of
large-scale data processing data
preparation formation learning is one of
the sweet spots in a way you know in
machine learning before you train you
have to prepare your data that typically
happens in batch mode know and then you
train and you create your model when
time comes to use your model for scoring
you have to take the input data and
prepare it in the exact same way that
you prepared it for training you know
not doing that you know is one of the
most common sources of problems with
machine learning and so beam allows you
to use that same pipeline that scoring
time now and scoring can happen as a
batch or stream and so again you get
that flexibility and that's the reason
why internally we really use the two
together very commonly and we've built
tools on top of Apache beam to make it
easier to prepare data for machine
learning and and prepare it for
tensorflow and those tools are being
open source as well and so again beam
and data flow are generate data pricing
services but really with a very strong
sweet spot for being used more and more
often in machine learning context and so
you know in a way this is this is what
it looks can all put together you know
in this case of streaming use case where
there are flows from whatever endpoint
mobile application
devices into an even worse like pub/sub
that we showed just earlier you know
server less even burrs or Kafka or
others into data flow for stream
processing and then straight into
bigquery all other systems you know big
table or GCS you know and then using
with ml so that's really where it fits
in that end-to-end pipeline and win is
going to show in in more detail what
dataflow does in practice yeah
absolutely so in the first pipeline we
utilize in a very simple example reading
messages directly from pub/sub and then
writing them directly to a big free
table in this particular example we're
going to break the glass and implements
more sophisticated analytics that will
be useful for deriving insight later on
as well as for deriving operational
insights that we can take advantage of
in the moment as they occur so you've
heard all about a lot about pub/sub as a
streaming data ingestion source Pop's
table can also be used as a source to be
written to that's the output of a
streaming data pipeline now in this
example I've enriched our pipeline with
some additional capabilities that can
leverage pub/sub capability to notify
downstream consumers of useful
information the first of this is a
product lookup web service the product
lookup web service enriches the
purchased information from all the
purchased goods information from the
checkout and then adds additional
information so it's an it it's an
example of a way to enrich incoming data
and then add additional information that
comes from external sources and then
write that information out to either a
batch source or to a streaming source
the second piece of information that
will be incorporating our external
sources into the pipeline is a inventory
web service and this could potentially
hold things like stock level another
inventory rate related information
now as purchases are being made from the
point-of-sale checkout we're going to be
integrating with the inventory web
service to update some information such
as the stock level for a product as well
as to produce alerts on particular
products are seeing spikes in
consumption which may be an indicator of
a stock-outs
in store hypothetically so with that in
mind I'd like to go into the demo to
show you what that might look like so
this next screen that I'm bringing up is
our new enhanced pipeline and you can
simply see by counting the number of
rectangles on the screen it must be
doing something pretty cool right so I'm
going to not talk about all the
different transformations that we're
applying this is producing some
analytical insights as well as some
operational insights but I'm going to
talk about the real-time stock
notification that I talked about earlier
so how can we notify Bill's grocery
stores whenever there's a threshold of a
particular product that's been exceeded
being purchased in a short period of
time so let's see how that actually
happens so first off we still need to
read the information so instead of
reading individual purchase information
now we're actually reading whole
invoices where there's one or more
purchases within it when we're doing
that we can perform more interesting
analytics things like obviously what is
the average size of an order and other
information like that after we read the
information we can augment that
information with additional information
from our product lookup service which is
where I'm actually hovering over right
now I want to focus on the operational
insights that we can enable by detecting
spikes in purchasing activity for
particular products and this is the part
of the pipeline which does that in order
to understand statistics and information
that occur within a period of time we
apply a technique called windowing in
this particular case it's a sliding
window aggregation across streaming data
that includes time timestamp information
that allows us to then count the number
of occurrences of a particular product
purchase over that period of time and
then if it exceeds a certain threshold
right a particular message to a pub sub
topic which is then used to or use by
downstream consumers to display an alert
so that's basically the right alerts to
pub actually should be pub sub
that's what that particular
transformation is doing so I think at
this point it might be more useful to
actually show this in action in our
hypothetical store scenario so Riza when
I'll start using this one okay okay all
right no so you need to go and start a
new order like so okay so let's assume
that it's been particularly heavy usage
of this it's a little bit towards the
end of day and we're looking for some
sugar fix I think it's just showing me
the one product okay okay all right so
someone is obviously a big fan of these
chocolate biscuits original or which I'm
only getting one packet but what this is
doing is sending the invoices one pops
up payload into our pipeline and then by
the streaming aggregation that's being
applied to the streaming data we should
see a alert come up to say that there's
a potential stop alert that has now
happened in the Penrith store in New
South Wales and so you see up on the
screen hopefully there that there's a
stock alert for that particular product
so this is an example of some
operational insight that you can get the
from streaming data not just things that
are written out to a big hurry table so
there's different ways that we can
operationalize insight that happens in
real time as well as for later
downstream analysis so with that I'll
pass back to you William and I'll also
press the button for it thank you so now
we can eat we're done with the props we
can we can start eating them okay good
we've been been three days we've been
looking at this packet and not touching
it so let's having done the data flow
demo i one thing i forgot to mention
data flows reports Java Python Scala
that our friends at Spotify contributed
there's a go SDK that's almost ready so
there's you know a choice of languages
here and yep I see the the biscuits are
passing see that's why you want to sit
in the front you get the biscuit so
lesson learn for next time um let's talk
about another service that approach that
so with the services we've talked about
so far perhaps our bigquery data flow
those are cognitive services
built from scratch to run in a
surveillance mode on Google Cloud
obviously there is also a lot of very
valuable systems in the open-source
community and in the Big Data space
spark and Hadoop I really - that come to
mind and we want to make sure that
customers on GCP can use whatever the
right tool for the job is and so if the
right tool is spark or Hadoop because of
you know some libraries some tool or
they've written already a lot of
pipelines on prayer on Prem and want to
run that on GCP that approach makes that
very easy by taking Hadoop and spark the
same Hadoop and spark that you know the
same bit from Apache everyone uses and
deploying them deploying a cluster in
about 90 seconds by the way you pay by
the second and so those clusters you
know it's it's a normal Hadoop and spark
cluster but it's also a very dynamic
cluster that you can start and you can
stop it and what it changes is the way
people typically use use it on cloud
where they don't have those long leaf
clusters now that people have to share
and you have to you know update them and
an agree on version it's a much more
dynamic way of getting a cluster for
whatever job you want to run and keep it
for one job for one day for one week and
really free yourself from all the
administration while keeping access to
the power and the ecosystem and all the
tools available and so when you use it
you can see on the left side a jobs API
where you can run your jobs and you can
write them using all the common tools in
the spark and Hadoop ecosystem and those
job execute on all the same data storage
systems that we talked about and so you
know I mentioned the cluster come up in
about 90 seconds when the cluster is up
you can start working right away well
the next step is not bring data to the
cluster like this in again remember no
silo like those Hadoop inspire clusters
can execute on data in bigquery under ah
in Google Cloud storage under are in
BigTable directly and I really lets you
mix and match you know across your
environment services like bigquery and
data flow what are cloud native
is Hadoop and spark using that approach
and use that all together I know again
use the right tool for the job and so
that that's a really powerful part of
that approach and let's look at in
practice again okay so I think we're
done without checkout so I can close
this window and instead show you the
data Pro console inside of the cloud
platform console so here we're seeing
the data proc list of clusters and I've
got one pre-prepared here but because
data proc starts up very quickly I'm
going to create a cluster on the fly so
let's give it a slightly unique name
like so I'm going to leave these sense
more defaults for the most part but
maybe change some specific things I
don't wanna call out when I'm creating
my my data prop cluster so the first is
maybe I want to specify a particular
region where runs so all my data is in
US central one so it makes sense to do
that we're using the sensible defaults
that I have for a very simple job that
I'm going to spin up which is to work
innards I can click on into Advanced
Options here before creating my cluster
and the first is the first thing I'm
going to do in the Advanced Options is
to allow API access from my cluster so
that my cluster can call different
Google cloud platform services to do
interesting things as well as install
some additional dependencies which I'll
altima need for my job so I click on
browse I'm going to point my data prop
configuration at a particular script
that I want data prop to run to install
some dependencies and then click on
select and from here I should be able to
create click on create and have my
cluster spun up with my custom
dependencies available on each worker so
to this point in time if I actually
describe what my job actually does so
let me rectify that particular situation
actually I can click on buckets here to
show you this information inside of our
project we have some hypothetical
customer feedback that some customers
are sent to us of which we're going to
and analyzed using a batch processing
job without cloud natural-language api
so we can understand the sentiment of
those emails and thereby be informed of
some actions to take because there's a
potentially unsatisfied customer that
you want to keep in touch or get in
touch with so let's have a look at the
emails or the input so we're in the
spark directory here which contains my
input now I've got two emails here as
text files and as we can imagine these
text files actually contain some some
angry sounding words in it and there's
some customer dissatisfaction there let
me just click on it just to prove the
fact that this particular person Bob is
not very happy but you can kind of get
the sense of what's within these emails
and the sort of sentiment that our batch
processing jobs should actually come
back with and of course I have my code
as well so we're not here to basically
step through Python so I won't actually
show you that but know that this is the
piece of code that I will then run by
submitting a spark job or PI spark job
more specifically to the cluster so that
was the data that I want to show in
order to submit a job I can actually
just click on a previous job here and
clone its configuration I want to do
that because I have all my previous
parameters already provided so I need to
type them in you can see that my Python
file is in this particular parameter
I've got my input pointing to the input
input directory which contains my emails
and I want the output to be sentiment
analysis output on each line in each
email written to a CSV file of course
the most important element is actually
choosing the cluster and the other
clusters actually come up now so that's
why I've got two available I'm going to
just gonna choose this particular
cluster click on submit oh whoops I
actually have to change the actual job
name because it needs to be unique
so and click on submit and my job should
be running now if I click into the
actual job
the streaming logging output from spark
should actually be displayed you'll see
Ashley it's probably too small to see
here but one interesting aspect of data
proc is its ability to talk directly to
Google Cloud Storage much like a normal
HDFS data source so there's no code
changes that you need in order to run a
job and data prop and have your data
stored on cloud storage and you get all
the scaling benefits of Google Cloud
storage as an object storage source so I
think now the job is actually complete
because I only have two emails in order
to prove the point I'm gonna go back to
my directory here and now there's an
output directory inside of my emails
bucket and here is the output of my
analysis with the batch processing job
I'm going to actually leave the output
of the national language API as a
discussion for Reza who will talk about
extending this with some additional
capabilities so Thank You Reza so one of
the interesting things that when
highlighted was the use of a API to
start extracting some structure from
unstructured content and actually when
you're building out on a platform you're
investing in that platform what you want
that platform to do is provide you with
all of the tools that you need to do all
of your work so a platform is a group of
technology used as a base to build other
things on top of and some of the other
tools that are available and we show a
small piece of it there is our machine
learning capability so things like
speech-to-text Cloud translation natural
language understanding these are all API
is that you want to be able to access
with your processing tools to be able to
extract information from that wealth of
unstructured content now let's expand
the use case that we just saw around the
providing sentiment against an email now
this is actually based off a real use
case with a retail customer let's
imagine you're getting emails and what
you want to do is when someone is
particularly angry or upset
you would like to put them onto a
priority queue because retaining
customers is expensive losing customers
even worse and what you don't want to do
is if there's something that you could
remediate the situation with for example
a seem simple set of vouchers or a
simple phone call or an email to
actually keep that customer you should
put them on top of the priority list
that one of our customers has an amazing
return on investment by doing just this
activity but we need to add a little bit
more so we can extract sentiment using
natural language processing API but we
also because we're storing this
information in another system we want to
not have the burden of actually taking
unnecessary information into the other
system so by that I mean if for example
we have the users name their email
they've accidentally put their credit
card we'd like help to actually remove
this information from that content
before we store it somewhere else you
know we want to avoid unnecessary for a
revelation of PII information so what
we're going to do is we're going to add
another piece which is the data loss
prevention API so this uses things like
machine learning pattern matching
[Music]
mathematical check sums etc to actually
find help find rid sensitive information
and then what it does is it allows you
to remove or start over that information
as you store it in another location so
what we're going to do now is go through
and just demo this what we're going to
do is show a particular data flow
pipeline so we saw data proper before
with the the natural language processing
here we have a data flow pipeline that's
going to be taking whenever a file lands
in Google Cloud Storage let's assume
that's an email it's going to take that
file and it's going to run it through
the two processes it's going to run it
through the data loss prevention API and
then the natural language understanding
API at the NLP API and at the end of
that it's going to store that
information in bigquery so right now
this has process up to Dowe three files
so I'm going to go to Google Cloud
Storage go to our email folder go to
inbound and I do have
a item ready upload files this Angry
British obviously there's no swearing in
it we don't do we don't do swearing in
Britain so we've got a language British
person who's going to update some
information that has been uploaded to
this cloud storage if I go to our thing
we're still at 3 what this will do is
when it detects of that file has landed
it's going to process it and land it
over here in this bigquery table so I'm
just gonna run this query here you can
see a fourth element has been added if I
go back we can see there that increment
it up to 4 so that's been processed
let's look at what it's done so I think
it was this one that landed so here
there's a very angry person who's the
birthday cake for their daughter's
birthday party arrived late
it has redacted information like their
credit card which they had put into the
piece and it also redacted their name it
was actually Reza there we also have a
sentiment score so this is like negative
4 with a high magnitude in other words
they were quite cross about having their
birthday cake arrive a day late we're
almost there in terms of having a full
foot workflow pipeline we've got as
emails are coming in we're able to do
this work and add them into bigquery but
what we haven't got is that final piece
of how do we notify our support people
to actually go and do something about
this and for that we need a bit of glue
to stick several processes together so
over to William quickly thank you and we
are switching back to slide and so I
think glue is a good term as which I
describe it because we've been talking
about individual services and what they
can do but now that our processing is
really an end-to-end experience and you
need something that ties together those
processing systems and gives you control
and visibility and a unified point of
Management and that's where a cloud
composer comes in composer is one of the
newer service on the platform it it went
generally available this week it is a
managed version of Apache airflow so if
you're familiar with Apache airflow
which
right now the in the open source
community the occupation service with
the most momentum are really really
loved by users and so we chose to use it
make it available as a managed service
on the platform contribute to air flow
bringing operators that allow it to act
on all the relevant Google cloud
services and make that available with no
deployment to all our users to easily
orchestrate and manage data processing
on Google cloud and so let's see what it
looks like in practice Reza's going to
do now is add that final piece which is
orchestrate moving the information that
exists in bigquery into a CSV file ready
for our support folks so I'm going to
use Google airflow here so Google
Composer
which is running an air flow job the tag
that I have in mind is going to do a
query against that bigquery table look
at the last two hours and then it's
going to put the result of that in
another table ready to be exported out
as a CSV file so oh so sorry now I'll
show you the yeah forgot to hit the
button follows you for that so here we
have the flow DAGs this is the notified
job if you can see it comes in two steps
recent query query and then export so
i'm going to go and even though this tag
is been scheduled to run every two hours
I'm going to just kick it off by
triggering the the process now and in a
moment we'll see these numbers we see it
already that the jobs being queued in a
moment we'll see both of those tasks
being processed successfully and the
move happening what that will do is it
will land a file if I go back to here
into our same emails but priority folder
so this was available from the last run
let's go back here and see if this is
already completed I'm gonna refresh the
page okay one task still running I'll
give that a few more moments and what
that would do is it's run the bigquery
sequel statement it's pushed some data
to another table it's done
the CSV export and landed that into
Google Cloud storage so if I just
refresh this there we go that task is
now completed if I go back to our bucket
and refresh this and now we download
this file I'll open it so this file now
since the last time it was run we have
one more email that we need to go and
deal with for this customer
so here composer has been used to glue
separate activities together to actually
generate a full workflow okay and with
that I would say William and back to the
demo slides and so actually having
talked about the the orchestration now
we're going to talk about the last stage
of the lifecycle which is all the tools
not all some of the tools that you can
use to directly interact with the data
and the win is going to demonstrate
those for us so up to this point in time
we saw a lot of sequel clearing which is
absolutely fantastic if you're
comfortable those tools sometimes you
want to visualize your information in
graphical ways or to explore your data
in intuitive environments that it let
you discover insight in a much more
visual way than what a sequel query can
give you so to that end I'm going to
show two different tools which are
integrated within the Google cloud
platform or integrated with Google cloud
platform rather and that tools or those
tools are Google Data studio which is a
dashboarding and visualization tool and
more recently a data exploration tool
integrated directly into bigquery and
the second tool that I'm going to show
is Google Spreadsheets which I think
many of you are familiar with today but
we recently just launched with a new
integration into bigquery so let's go
into demonstration mode again
okay the first thing I want to show you
is data studio Explorer and that is our
intuitive exploratory environment that
integrates into bigquery I'm going to go
into one of our big three tabs here and
again I'll kick start our analysis using
a saved query in this case I'm going to
be interested in the top products
purchased together with bakery goods
this information is actually computed or
the table is actually computed by the
output from our streaming pipeline that
does a lot more the operational insights
and the analytics from from previously
so this query here is going to run
across I think about 70 million rows or
maybe even more actually we're still
receiving data so there's quite a lot of
information still coming in but it's
going to be giving us quite a lot of
results and it should usually finish
right about now okay so in our output we
see that there's individual product
combinations and the amount of revenue
associated with the other product that's
been bought with a bakery item this is
quite difficult to actually comprehend
in this interface so what I'm going to
do now is take this into exploration
mode via data Shido Explorer so I've
done that by clicking on the explore
button inside of the bakery in the face
and now I've got an environment work and
intuitively slice and dice and explore
the data set in a much more visual way
on the right hand side we have different
ways to visualize the information using
different types of graphs scatter plots
line charts bar charts that sort of
stuff in this case I'm going to choose a
pivot table to show some specific
insight about how products are being
bought with bakery items in this case
how much revenue is what in total
brought in in total for a products
bought with bakery items so I'm going to
change one of the dimensions here so
that we're actually looking at the
product revenue
so with that we changed the actual
metric into revenue instead of frequency
and we see that builds brand organic
honey is actually doing really quite
well so let's do another type of
visualization inside a data studio
Explorer and this time this view the
proportion of revenue attached to bakery
goods as in the form of a pie chart so
in this case let's again look at the
metric as product revenue so we'll drop
that in there like that oh actually I
think it's already in there okay so
let's just say that I'm happy with this
particular visualization and I want to
incorporate it into a larger dashboard
so what I can do now is actually save
this exploration and then after this is
saved I can export it to a report Oh
actually I don't to create a new report
because I've actually got a great one
ready to show you so I'm going to copy
to existing report so this is going to
copy this pie chart and it's going to be
now available for me to paste into an
existing dashboard that I already have
so this is the dashboard here so this
dashboard shows the different types of
visualization capabilities in one
convenient screen so here you find ways
to visualize information in tabular
formats as well as line charts bar
charts and other types of information or
types of ways to visualize inflation
rather so let's just say that I want to
incorporate my pie chart into this
dashboard what I'm gonna do is paste my
pie chart into this dashboard and then
fill out the last missing piece of
information I wanna show and then bring
it down now if you use gee suite
products you might know that a lot of it
is real-time collaboration based and
data studio in this respect is no
different so I think right now I've
actually got William or somebody posing
as William ie Reza inside the dashboard
at the same time working to update the
dashboard for improved aesthetics as you
can as you can see right now so this is
a great real-time collaboration tool
where you can work with others to create
a dashboard and then share it to other
people for further collaboration or to
just visualize the dashboard as a
consumer of this information okay and
Reza's very helpfully just shrunk my
graph for me which has again made an
aesthetic improvement I think it's now
ready to then share with somebody else
so let's complete the final step and
share it to Callie
which is somebody that is interested in
this insight I can send the report to
that person they'll get a link and then
they can basically see the same
dashboard as well actually maybe not in
this particular case let's try one more
time let's say view instead and yes and
there you go Kelly now has access so
there you go I want to pass over to Reza
to show one final piece which is the
Google Spreadsheets integration so this
was very recently announced as well so
this is Google sheets and just very
quickly gonna run through here in the
sheet if I go to the data a column so in
Google sheets now at the bottom we now
have data connectors and we can choose
bigquery here I'll be able to choose a
project so let's go to our da next
project do a right here we see the
information the story the data sets etc
available to us if I just go back here I
have created a data set already if we
remember we were scanning some products
in this happens to be the product code
that was available here we have the
sheet which is actually going to that
table and X listening information if i
refresh this sheet it's going to get the
very latest data that we had based off
the demo so these were the last items
and plenty of chocolate biscuits are
being bought in this time so this is a
very quick nice and easy Google sheets
integration with bigquery okay
Thank You riza switch back to the slides
and so having shown of an overview of
the platform and no services like
pub/sub bigquery data flow data proc we
know here you see simplified example
with this you know SoDo point-of-sale
and and simplify things about really
just to show what each product does in a
very concrete and an applied way but now
let's look at a real life scenario and
how that's being used by in this case
Maluku and hiddenly
is joining us to talk about their
experience on the platform thank you
William for the introduction my name is
Hayden Lee I'm a research scientist at
Moloko I've been with Malaka for about
two years yeah so I will briefly talk
about the company mobile call and what
we do so we are a mobile ed tech company
that turns big data into add performance
using machine learning models our
clients use us for marketing purposes
like user acquisition and re-engagement
as well as monetization of their
products our cloud solution is deeply
integrated with Google cloud platform
so in particular we use BigTable
bigquery data flow and pops out the
products that we use so in this session
some of the challenges we face while
building a scalable addict of the
solution was can be summarized as these
three things and I'm gonna talk about
how we have overcome these challenges
using some of the products of Google
cloud platform so the first thing that
comes to my mind is the small latency
requirement with a high volume of
network traffic so for mobile
advertisement as soon as the user opens
on app and the shows an ad like an image
or video will receive an event that is
called a bit request from the bid
exchange servers so those are
third-party services that we are
integrated with and as soon as we
receive a bid request we have to respond
within 100 milliseconds we have to
determine whether we want to participate
in this real-time auction or not and how
much price we're willing to pay and what
kind of image or videos we want to serve
and if the user clicks on it where the
user should be
- so we have to do all that on there 100
millisecond for each request and we
receive about over 600,000 bid requests
per second at peak and we receive over
40 billion bid requests per day so that
is one of the challenges we faced and
latency is a big problem we have to
solve so for that we use BigTable I will
talk a little bit more about this later
transforming big data into machine
learning models is another challenge we
use a lot of complex machine learning
models and to do that we have to be able
to process a large volume of data and we
have to transform that data into
something that we can our machine
learning algorithms can process and
digest so we use data flow for that and
we process over 100 terabytes of new
data on a daily basis and we also have
the accumulated data over the course of
two to three years that that we use to
train our machine learning models the
third challenge was to find a
collaborated tool that can handle big
data as well as complex analysis so for
that we use bigquery as you saw from the
demos in the by win by win and Reza we
use bigquery to save views or queries
and share those with the team members
our data scientists the modelers want to
analyze big data using complex queries
sequel or user defined functions and
also sometimes it's very helpful to
share the quarries themselves so with
that in mind I'm gonna give you a
high-level overview of how we are using
each of these Google cloud platforms
product to build our application so on
the left-hand side you see two boxes
that are labeled as real-time bidding
exchanges and mobile measurement
platforms so those are the third part
third-party services that we are
integrated with there are dozens of them
and we receive live traffic from them so
as soon as we receive a bid request or
some other events from these services
Google's load balancer will handle them
and reroute them to our live feed
servers our life be the servers are
written in golang and they are they are
running on top of kubernetes
engine so those two red boxes represent
our so serving module there are some
other components like pops up but it's
not in this
diagram because we are gonna focus on
data processing in this session so for a
big data processing we primarily use for
products data flow along with BigTable
the query and Google Cloud Storage so
I'm going to talk more about these
products and how we use them for
modeling especially handling large data
sets tensorflow is an open source
library released by Google and our most
of our machine learning motels are
written in written using tensor flow so
if we zoom into data processing as I
mentioned we process over 100 terabytes
of data on a daily basis so the data
flow just can read from and write to
BigTable B Cori Google Cloud storage
including pub/sub as you saw from the
demo earlier so we use dataflow to
primarily transform one complex data
structure into another so we keep
transforming data depending on our needs
and then eventually our goal is to make
it available at a time of bidding so
that we can make an informed decision
about how we want to participate in a
real-time auction and also to train our
machine learning models so we are on a
daily basis we learn over 250 data flow
batch jobs and some of the largest jobs
use over for thousands of virtual CPUs
per job and most of our jobs are CPU
intensive because they're transforming a
very complex data data structure to
another we also utilize data flows
service space to shuffle it's an opt-in
feature that you can use I'm going to
talk about this a little later and it
actually gave us a huge performance
gains in terms of throughput per cost
before I talk about some of the benefits
we've we got by using Google cloud
platform I also want to emphasize how we
were able to scale while keeping the
cost low in the past two years so we
have grown from serving 60,000 QPS to
600,000 QPS in the past few years so
there's a 10 times growth in in the
number of beads so here in the chart the
x-axis is a month and y-axis on the left
hand side is the number of beads or
auctions we participated in in a given
month the blue bars represent that so
you can clearly see a fast growing trend
here the red line represents the
cause our unit infra cost per bids so if
the people it's been going down by a
factor of three in the past two years so
we have been able to do that while even
though our developer team was pretty
small we started with two full-time
engineers and now we're about ten
full-time engineers the whole company
has grown from about I think seven
people to about 45 people now in the
past two years so we were able to do
that because our IT operations burden
was very low so most of the products
that we use on Google cloud platform are
handled by Google cloud engineers and
Google cloud support team so we don't
have to worry about operating those
tools like for example BigTable B Korea
and dataflow we just have to worry about
improving our applications at cloud
solutions so we were able to improve our
tools build new features and add more
tools but we didn't really have to focus
human resources on this operations
aspect so that way we were able to grow
really fast while scale scale up really
fast while keeping the unique cost very
low and here the unique cost in terms of
infra as well as human resources so in
summary I can't mention I can list these
five and four benefits of using JCP and
then in the next two slides I'm gonna
talk a little more about specific use
case studies we benefited from using GCP
so the first thing that comes to my mind
is a pay-as-you-go pricing model so when
we were a very small company we only we
were not able to come into a huge like
amount of resources like CPUs or memory
or virtual machines because we were not
receiving that much traffic but now if
you are building a scalable application
keeping the unit costs the same or lower
will be very beneficial as you grow
because overall your applications
scalability is going up as you as long
as your unit price is at level or going
down so that's exactly what we did and
now that we have grown quite a bit
we are also utilizing what is called the
community use discount so we have
committed to you
a certain amount of V CPUs and virtual
machines in each of the each of the
major regions in that Google cloud
platform provides so we are able to cut
down our infrared bill as well another
aspect is this was mentioned earlier in
the session too but easy integration
among many products of GCP in particular
my personal experience using data flow
together with BigTable Vickery and
Google Cloud Storage has been very
useful because I didn't they provide a
lot of useful API like and documentation
so operationally we didn't really need a
separate operations team there is
separated from developers team so we
didn't really need to worry about how we
are gonna manage or operate or deploy
some of the services offered by Google
cloud platform because they are all
handled by Google so there has been very
very useful for us Stack Overflow is a
great resource for asking technical
questions on some of these products
personally I've asked a bunch of
questions about data flow and BigTable
and stack overflow and the team members
team engineers at Google actually
responded to some of my questions and
they were very helpful so this one of
the great resources public resources you
can utilize in the next two slides I'm
gonna talk more specifically about our
case studies of how we utilize data
flows service-based shuffle which is an
opt-in feature and also how we use the
table and bigquery as complements to
overcome the three major challenges I
mentioned earlier so data flow service
space shuffle is basically an opt-in
feature the data flow back in the server
provides so you pay based on the amount
of data processed by the server but in
exchange your jobs throughput and
performance is in terms of job duration
are expected to get better so in this
chart the top chart shows the job the
same job CPU utilization without the
shuffle service and the bottom chart
shows it with the shuffle service so the
images are of the same size but the
first job took about four hours and the
second
took about three hours and y-axis is a
CPU utilization as I mentioned earlier
our most of our jobs are very CPU
intensive so if CPU utilization is low
that means our jobs throughput is not at
kick so clearly you can see how it is
better with the second job when we
turned on shuffle service and overall
you can also save because your job
duration is shorter you will pay less
for the resources you used for running
those data flow jobs but you also you
can also save your cost by cutting down
memory or disk spaces used by this date
of dataflow jobs so overall in this
specific case it he gave us a three
times improvement in throughput per cost
and we use this shuffle service for some
of our batch jobs whenever they is
applicable another thing I want to
emphasize is how we use BigTable be
Korean dataflow together as complements
so as I mentioned earlier the for one of
the challenges we have is latency
requirement so BigTable for quick access
is basically how we have overcome the
first challenge the table offers quick
key value operations both reason writes
10,000 QPS under 60 millisecond and
that's actually very quick and we really
need this to meet the 100 millisecond
requirement and it also offers fast
scans using data flow so 200 megabytes
per second and this is per node so we we
store a lot of data in BigTable that is
required for we are determining whether
we want to participate in a real-time
bidding or not and also for our machine
learning models they have to determine
what bid price we are going to like
write and submit to those exchanges so
we we have a lot of data stored in
BigTable
and the data flow is one one way to scan
through this BigTable and store the
resulting data set in bigquery or Google
Cloud Storage also garbage collection is
very easy with different types of
garbage collection policies so there's
another bit a useful feature for
BigTable and bakura is more suitable for
complex analysis so our data scientists
and modelers
to use bigquery to analyze complex data
including our training data sets or
machine learning models so sequel and
user defined functions are supported and
also we use live we use stream insert
for real-time monitoring monitoring and
analytics so our live video servers
will stream insert some of the data some
like logs and some matrix to bigquery
tables and also as you saw from the demo
it is very easy to share queries and
views
so this basically solved our third
challenge where we need a color
collaborative tool that can handle big
data and it is very easy to share within
the organization and also as you saw
from the demo garbage collection policy
or table exploration can be set so
there's another plus to utilize both of
these products we use dataflow as the
main product that does data
transformation so specifically for our
machine learning pipeline we have to
generate a large collection of data sets
for to train our models and evaluate
them so most valuable information or
data set is stored in BigTable because
they are read and written by our live
feed servers so we use dataflow job to
scan whole BigTable and dump that data
to Google Cloud storage as well as
bigquery the reason we write the data to
two different places is because Google
Cloud Storage is basically just a
storage we store all of our data there
on the other hand the quarry is suitable
for complex analysis so we are gonna
transform this data the same data that
we read from BigTable in a way that our
modelers and data scientists can easily
analyze on bigquery using C curve so
that's how we try out to regenerate
machine learning data training data sets
and and then our data our tensor flow
models will train from those data sets
so just to wrap up Malaka has grown
rapidly in the past two years and
scalability has been the key to our
growth Google cloud platform helped us
to focus more on developing our
application at cloud solution without
having to worry about operating
these cloud services that you sell from
this session so in particular by using
BigTable Vickery data flow we were able
to overcome the three major challenges I
mentioned in the first slide and that's
how we have been able to sort of work
with some of the largest clients we have
like largest e-commerce in Asia or one
of the largest electronic device makers
so with that I'm gonna give this back to
William and yeah thank you thank you
very much hidden thank you and so just
in closing you see the three principles
which I describe in an abstract way at
the beginning hopefully by now you see
how in practice you know the data
integration delivers on the integrated
part of composer tying things together
how pub/sub answer and data flow and
bigquery really exemplify serverless for
that are processing and how whether it's
bringing the best of open source to
Google with that approach with composer
or vice versa bringing Google technology
to open source we stand surf low and
Apache beam and others we live by this
this principle of everything we do being
based on open technology and so
hopefully that give you a quick overview
of how we apply those principles a quick
overview of the capabilities of some of
the key services
[Music]